that's just a low-percentage to play
there by the Hawks neat pick it right up
and come on down the offensive that
didn't go with his only shot of the game
getting it from man 23 the last 13 from
downtown
[Applause]
it defense is so spread out here on the
breakdown because they're so worried
about the three-point shooting it
essentially is a one on one play
look at all that room that Jimmy has no
one coming over from the weak side so
the lamest 12th triple of a hand puts
them up nine to the future downtown and
hits the line the five points in the 47
so far if it has got the hot hand he was
four for six before knocking that last
one down
found the right game the wash its BAM
putting on his skill set with the steel
on a left hand delivery finding Jimmy on
the move
they're 12 and 2 against teams in the
east and they're perfect for a know
against team to their own division
Butler but he's gonna read the game and
do what he has but he already has two
triple-double uses get close to another
[Applause]
[Music]
Ezra Pound number 13 for Jimmy buckets
[Applause]
doesn't have the healthy that they're
not set up he finds the seam accelerates
gets to the body there of Jones with
that left shoulder shields the ball
delivers the blow and is able to get the
ball up and make down by 333 seconds
left
in 117 is first triple of the game
give me use block here to society
[Applause]
he is tied the franchise record with his
10th triple routing Brian Shaw
[Applause]
[Music]
fishing touches keep them
he's got wisdom to share and he's very
free sharing it not only with his
teammates but any player in the store
it'll be taking is eight points to the
free-throw line
[Music]
he's got six points but I love his
ability to finish after content really
likes to get to that dribble pull-up
game or that runner Oh
now Trey Young is walking over toward
that bench for Atlanta he'll come out of
the game as well john bam adebayo very
intelligent player besides being so
athletically gifted you can feel this
one at home boom right there that is
just points off that Lana's bench all
here in the second quarter the Hawks at
7:30
[Applause]
third nbac and it's the fear if you're
my faith scored a ton of points without
Trey on contributing much of the first
half and they still school six Katrina
crisis came and hammers it home as
Willis bunker shot up for the field
tonight he's one of four at the line
Adebayor
[Applause]
- you three banditogaming time 45 Lenin
here comes bad
the fan express coming right at you
[Music]
we're six and oh and they have 30
assists or more because of the escape
trouble for Pam he is 23 need scoring
the first 7 points here in overtime
[Applause]
keeper a potential three-point play it
inside nice drop off by Duncan fakes the
behind the back freezes Ben's partner so
he doesn't make a play on it and just
the and Duncan to three
to set the record for three
vo finishing touches
performance triple-double of the career
for Butler and his third this season
they've become very very reasonable